so you probably heard that old adage
that every person is at least one good
book in them I believe in something
grander than that I believe that every
great person has at least one great beer
all they need is a fearless brewer like
me to coax it out welcome
so that's odd let's drink it hello
you're here just let me know when we
start to roll okay ready
hello widow's ears sit up sit up
straight today we are here in sunny
downtown Los Angeles at Sweeney's Ale
House and I'm here with my college
buddies Joe lo Truglio and Ken Marino
who are killing it as in Hollywood as
actors and shows like Mary me and
Brooklyn nine-nine but today I am gonna
kill them or at least their taste buds
we're gonna take them on an epic IPA
voyage an IPA of course is India Pale
Ale that's the fastest Italian radaway
toxins and at any rate we've been
brewing SuperDuper hoppy beers at
dogfish Head for almost two decades
well secret 13 years but we've never
really attempted to brew the hoppiest
beer ever proven to be brewed by mankind
probably a good reason for them yeah
that'd be dangerous our goal here join
us who is max headroom before unleashing
like crazy experiment on Kennon gel i
need to build up their tolerance for
hops with a tasting of the three
hoppiest beers dogfish Head currently
has in production the 60 90 and 120
Minute IPA hops are a flowering plant
and the ALF acid in the female plant is
what gives bitterness to beer especially
the mouth puckering India Pale Ales that
now dominate the market brewers measure
the ha penis in beer in IBUs or
international bittern units those light
lagers you see everywhere on TV they're
about six ideas the insane beer
Brewed for Ken and Joe today clocks in
at over 658 ideas we're going to start
at 60 and work our way up
do you guys remember when we first
started hanging out and drinking beers
you would like a handsome model back in
the late mid to late 1990s but then it
was the downfall yeah fear fear and when
they said okay now would you really
camera pose what's your other low yeah
yeah what's your other look like you
know I'd be like yeah that's right and
then they were like maybe get into
something here I remember we were
roommates it and I remember that you had
a three keg set up regular kegs or kegs
that you had seen a cake party and then
somehow you divert them together and you
brewed beer that way in our apartment
yep the first time I ever served home
ruin our apartment most of the cast of
the state was there and I was like as I
love me working that butter a very good
stuff Ricki Lake was there I don't know
if you remember that I made a pale ale
for the first one with cherries and it
stood up on our coffee table Ricki Lake
as my witness and you guys and said this
is what I'm gonna do in my life what do
you guys think it's fine it's very good
this is xline it's very tasty beer I
don't understand the whole IPA craze
they've existed in England since the
1800s but the IPA style is the fastest
growing beer style in America I did not
know that until now I cannot go to a
restaurant without hearing somebody go
uh.what la pa do you have what's your
IPA WoW is that your beer deputy who I
paid a home Italia when I drink a beer I
want something that has a kind of bite
to bite a bite
that's what IPA is right yeah that bite
is the bitterness the earthiness the
herbaceousness of the hops baisha sness
it's a word you guys have kids do you
ever use that that's it like don't be so
audacious
do you ever when they don't bathe
IPAs are truth serums particularly as
he's that true yeah and if you walk up
in bitterness and intention to me right
so what do you mean it's a truth serum
what the hell is that is we with good
friends you haven't seen each other for
a while oh you mean the drunker you get
the more loose-lipped you get not
drunker just the more you're enjoying
your beer please don't use drunk on this
show you can't say drunk I know you do I
object Sam yes that's a CIA know about
this truth serum deal with it IPAs so I
feel like you can get in on some great
government contracts here
all right so now you have a 90 minute
now all right this one's a little bit
more reddish hue it's basically like 60
minute condensed remember this thing you
used to do to get the foam down oil the
oil he knows is that does that really
work it does so what is the difference
between 68 90 in like 120 minute I paid
basically want to take sixty minutes
yeah to do something right mm-hmm
to boil is that right once the beer
starts boiling in the boil kettle that's
like the Brewers equivalent of a chef's
spiced pot on this one spice that every
brewer ads is hops when you're brewing
the beer you're adding the hops in the
boil kettle for bitterness and the
earlier in the process you add them the
more they contribute to the to the taste
and bitterness they're early rap yep and
the later you add them in the process
they more they contribute to the aroma
so basically all time its duration of
the boil but also the Holy Trinity of
beer other than water is barley hops and
yeast okay right the hops gives the
bitterness to the beer barley is what
gives you your fermentable sugars yeast
is the living organism that eats the
sugars poops out alcohol and farts co2
bubbles so that's how your beer is made
I do smell the East farts and this is
how you sell a cue it's how you describe
the process of fermentation this is
delicious
so this is the 120 notice the difference
in color unlike the other beers this
beer is unfiltered so it's pretty damn
hazy how much nose oil did you get there
it's a lot different than the 60th a 90
right heavier that's not true I'm just
it is Vicker than the others this is the
strongest IPA in America between 16 and
18 percent alcohol which is higher yeah
which is why we we do smaller smaller
portions but it doesn't take didn't
taste it wasn't strong it's 90 yeah I
remember how early wine yep when we used
to steal things from bars we never did
that we never did that ever did that
those I'm kidding yeah this is sweeter
yes good point Joe because we're yeast
Marlow more barley so when you're
brewing beer is this strong the yeast is
eating the formidable sugars but in a
certain alcohol content the alcohol
itself becomes toxic to the cell wall
these yeah yeah no no what so he was
talking about BER brewing beer to the
point where I fell asleep
ah so I was talking about when the yeast
eats the sugar in the beer uh-huh and
the lease is what creates Joe OH
what comes Joe becomes Sam is just
describing the really fascinating part
totally does that y'all right so you
guys are more like into just enjoying
the beer and not over no no no no it's a
good tense you know actually I'm
interested I am what Magus is this is an
entertainment
so guys we've done some tests to try and
brew the hoppiest commercial beer how do
you gauge every the amounts of science
we sent out to an independent lab and
prove that this is the hoppiest beer
commercially ever brewed how did you do
it
yep here's how we did it most hops used
in brewing come in pelletized or holy
form for this beer we created super
concentrated extracts and oils from
specially grown experimental hops to
achieve uncharted levels of bitterness
120 Minute IPA we drank is about 120
IBUs cradling and the beer can enjoy are
about to drink is a face melting 658 IBS
it's been verified by an outside lab as
the hoppiest commercial beer ever made
and my plan is that these guys will
become the first brave civilians to
taste it outside our brewery what's the
name of your beer
whoo LOD what lon is that the name of
the beer H oh oh la WD two words to do
shame is not set in stone
I assume that you have saloon doors at
your brewery do you walk in like dogfish
facilities always we need to make the
strongest IPA that's the vision I had
this morning he's got a cigar that's
almost burned down
we need to Richter we gotta make that
strongest are you about the IPA hey I'm
lefty so tray here see here you hops
stack ready for the next step for us
we're ready yeah
how about a nice IPA
thanks to cool us cuz it cool on that's
a hoppy beer ok a 28 and action have a
beer now thanks Jeff
hey Laurie that's some hop it cut I'll
pay how bad what's with the accent man
have a beer
oh that's yes ah happy hey I'll tell you
what - a bit cut no you didn't want to
do another take he's scared we all right
warning he'll be alright
we go in action have a beer can oh
thanks Joe whoooo does the summer hoppy
beer
cut let's break for lunch and a meatball
you